WHOA!
Whoa. Whoah!
Hold up–
His chin is breathing!
Here we go!
OHH
What the heck??
Wait–
What?
Wait what?
WHAT?
Thanks to Skillshare for sponsoring this video.
Stick around to the end to figure out how you can get two free months of premium membership.
*clap*
Hey guys, we're back!
It's Bollywood time!
We actually have NO idea what any of these people
are saying,
but we know there's a visual effect in there somewhere.
I'm excited to hop in.
I have a whole coffee in my system and I'm ready!
Why do I always have to be in the back of the couch?
'Cause you're the tallest.
Did you guys know, I'm actually part Indian?
I'm legit actually part Indian.
Dude–
This guy– This guy's gonna get clipped.
This guy's gonna get clipped hard.
It's this Duh-hoom?
DHOOM
Oh, he's undercover?
Wait, he's suspicious.
*record scratch*
He is standing on a manhole cover (Yeah, n-no)
That is INSTANTLY suspicious.
He's going in– he's going down
I think he's going up!
I don't think he's that old!
Yeah, he's DEFINITELY not old.
That's makeup.
Oh, and– Time out.
All right votes.
Is he going up or down on that manhole cover?
I think he's going down
and then he's gonna reemerge anew.
Oh, that would be the Bollywood way.
Oh, man.
I think Clint's on to something here.
All right.
Here we go!
He's only going one way.
OHH
What the heck??
Wait-
(laughing)
Wait what??
WHAT??
That was NOT what I–
Hold on!
What is the liquid?
Oh no, he's going down, that's acid.
The comp on that is HORRIBLE.
The white edges they're– it's– so small?
It was just that first shot though,
'cause the rest of the acid actually looks not that bad...?
The left one is the one that's drawing my eye
because it looks like a Video Copilot blood squirt.
Blood squirt turned green.
It looks like it's splashing out as opposed to rolling across the ground there.
The end of it is actually disappearing.
It's the white halo on them that really gets me.
But then it cuts to the next shot,
where you actually see the acid starting to pool on the ground
and NOW that is an actual liquid simulation that
we're seeing.
It's actually not bad.
No, I agree,
and you're getting that, like, specular highlight stuff
going on.
It's the A man.
OHH
Ahhh!
Down!
Where did he go? Where did he go??
They're like NOO
(mocking) "Oh my god! He has fooled us!"
He fooled me, too!
WHOA, WAIT!
OH, HE'S COMING BACK UP!!
HE'S COMING BACK UUUPPP
(laughing)
And he's all DECKED!
He's DECKED!
OH he's got on ROLLER BLADES!
He's got ROLLER BLADES!
Called it!
God dang it!
Look at him go!
Clint, you're right, you just forgot the rollerblades!
And he's gotta do a trick!
You have to do a TRICK!!
And POSE all cool over those cars man!
'Cause Bollywood is just a contest of how cool
you can look
when you're in an action scene!
He had his effects makeup artist take off his
face makeup.
Oh, hell yeah.
This is–
This is awesome.
These shots are legit!
Look how fast!
He hits ONE pothole and he is done.
They're doing a really good job at making everything feel like it's at full speed.
Yeah, yeah
Like, the cars are moving at like a normal highway speed
The wide shot, like those shots right there.
Usually when you fast forward stuff, it has like that very jittery motion.
That's very easy to tell that something's been
fast-forwarded
Generally, you're limiting yourself to like
25, 30 miles an hour
if you have like a human outside of the vehicles
Because the moment you start going any faster with a person there?
It's kind of like guaranteed death
if something goes wrong.
So you always have to find creative ways
to kind of keep things looking like they're moving at a normal speed.
It's what they did for Matrix Reloaded on the highway scene
Everyone's just kind of driving at a slow speed and as long as you keep the camera steady and smooth enough
You can fast-forward it and make it look full speed without the shakiness coming in.
Oh.
Alright.
You got the helicopter team. They got the sniper.
CG helicopter.
Whoa– Whoawhoawhoawhoawhoa
So is that full CG?
That helicopter flying through the city there?
It looks full CG to me.
It looks like a 2D card!
it was probably a real helicopter filmed on a plate
that they extracted from that plate and put into
the scene
and then animated it to come closer to camera.
You can tell that because
the actual orientation of the helicopter doesn't change as it goes from really far away to close to camera.
It stays the same.
Wren did that in real life.
Look at those muzzle flashes tho.
Yeah, the muzzle flashes in this are pretty– pretty beautiful.
I think that's a three frame muzzle flash.
I just want to count how many frames that thing is.
Alright. One–
What a beautiful little muzzle flash.
It's just one??
It's all about, like, the tiny, like, lingering dust ball,
Now he's really gonna get him this time.
The helicopter moves towards the left of the frame
Whereas the little smoke thing there literally doesn't move at all.
It's like untracked. (Yeah.)
But they're also in a helicopter moving sideways really, really quickly
Maybe that was an attempt to make it look like it was flying backwards.
But, you know, kudos to them for putting a reflection of the muzzle flash–
Yeah, yeah. Yeah!
–in the glass.
And they put lighting!
They put lighting on the door. And him.
They actually did the proper compositing for this.
They just got the scale of the muzzle flash wrong.
It's still a beautiful little muzzle flash.
I just wanted to let the artist know we appreciate it.
Hey, Nick!
Get ready to pan, slash, tilt to the trash can, okay?
Oh my god, settle your heart rate.
Guys, guys
I just finished this coffee.
All right?
I'm gonna– I'm gonna ace this right into this trash can
If I make it–
If I make it, you HAVE to subscribe.
Okay?
All right. Here we go.
Three two one–
*yeet*
Hey, hey, hey!
Hey! (laughing)
Hey!
(laughing)
Keep it together Clint!
If you're subscribed– If you're subscribed–
Don't unsubscribe!
Take a few deep breaths...
(wheezing) He totally went for the shot!
I can already–
Your heart rate's at, like,
160–
I'm like a hamster!
My heart rate's like a frikin' hamster's heart.
Let's go!
Tumbbad!
Tumbbad.
A wall of flesh? That's pulsing?
And a man with a lantern?
I– I'd–
I love this by the way.
I'm sold.
That mustache! (Ohh)
That shadow!
This is great.
Yeah, this is cool.
I don't care what it's about. I'm down.
It's a genie.
*gasp*
A de- A demon genie!
Is he the genie?
Is this what the inside of a bottle looks like?
(laughing) Meat walls...
Dude, if I was a genie in a bottle I'd be pissed.
Uh oh,
That's the perspective of a creature.
OH
Got 'em.
Ah–
So scary
So I'm super confused right now.
Like this is just a set.
This is just a meaty set.
There's no way this is a CG set.
(old man wailing)
Ohh!
His chin is breathing!
Oh man, brutal!
Like, the set's real, and like there's tons of practical makeup going on.
But all that pulsing and twitching you see
I'm pretty sure it's– that's added in later.
Basically, you're just applying a little bit of distortion to give it that, like,
"alive" kind of movement.
Yeah, but it's- it's definitely done well.
It's really subtle.
(hissing)
Uh oh! Monster man!
Is the monster real or CG? (Whoa!)
Dude that particle??
Oh, that's CG.
Oh, he's CG.
Wow, this is great.
(lots of snarling and growling and scratching)
Whaaaat?
What just–?
Sorry, this is just getting crazy.
Is he poopin' out coins?
Gettin' that butt moneyy
Okay, it is a pouch.
I was kinda confused what kind of opening that was...
The set definitely looks practical
and that's when you can compare the actual, like,
the slimy factor and the reflections off of the set to the CG character.
They're very close.
The lighting is actually really good on the creatures
The rendering is pretty good, but I feel like the material doesn't QUITE line up to the set as well.
The specular highlights are very broad and kind of dim and going across like
his whole hand there, his face.
There's another shot where you see like some actual physical prop guts and stuff
the highlights are way sharper and they're way smaller
and there's way more of them,
whereas on the creature they're a little bit dimmer, a little bit more spread out.
I see what you're saying, totally.
When you're building like a 3D material,
generally you're given like a few basic settings
What's the flat color that you're trying to render?
Then you can change the specular settings which dictate how reflective certain things can be
You have another setting for roughness, which is, for instance:
The roughness of my watch face is basically zero because it's reflecting everything perfectly
but you have the roughness of maybe this bottle for instance and you see how it's not a flawless pristine reflection.
There's only so many properties you can tweak
but when it comes to a character that's covered in blood and dirt and is made out of skin and has a crown,
you start to get into these situations where you have a lot of these different elements interacting in really unique ways.
That when you just try and apply like a single texture to a creature you're not able to fully capture what that would actually look like.
Yeah, but I mean look at that shot there.
What works in their favor so well is the single point of light right in the center of the scene.
All of the monsters are actually lit REALLY well.
Yeah, I love it.
I'm just saying, like, you're not seeing the right combination
all these properties trying to be forced into one.
I– I think a big thing that throws off this effect for me
is the movement–
a little too perfect.
A lot of it feels like it's animated by hand.
I don't feel like they had a person with, like, a Mocap suit necessarily for this.
It was more like they filmed someone doing the actions,
Probably did some paint out,
and then had someone go in by hand to recreate the character's motion.
Honestly, like, the monster work in this movie is really solid.
Yeah. It looks pretty friggin' good to me.
This is a really cool movie.
I kind of want to see it.
I guess it's on YouTube
and you can just go watch it right now if you want!
Singham is a great film.
We've actually gone through this movie before,
but there are more scenes to be discovered.
Like, the whole genre of the Indian Maverick cop.
I love it.
Like, India's version of superheroes like Captain America, you know?
Except he's like Captain India.
Oh, no.
Is he wobbling it?
I think he wobbles this for a good, like, minute.
(fast forward noises)
(RIP LAMPOST)
Oh, god. Here we go.
(laughing) Is he gonna bonk 'em with a lightpost?
He's ready to play some Beat Saber.
Single arm Beat Saber (laughing) with a staff
There he goes!!
Oh, no.
*mimicking scene*
WHOAA
Done, dude.
Deceased.
(tires screeching)
(crash)
Whoa! (Holy crap.)
Whoa!
Hold up.
Wait, what?
That was real!
That, like–
Those were not CG people.
That was a real stunt there.
Obviously there had to have been wires that they painted out.
Oh! (Oh no.)
More wire work.
Pah!!
The biggest–
Not but like he–
got hit in the back of the head,
that causes him to fly up!
(laughing)
Uh ohhhh!
He's like: "Whoaa!"
You can't–
This dude just outran a car!
You can't outrun this dude!
Here comes a slap, dude.
Oh, it's a slap?
Is this the power slap?
Oh, no!
*slap*
Ohohohoho
(laughing)
I love this.
"Get back here!"
(*SNAP*)
(whooosh)
Yeah–
That last shot looked really weird, by the way.
The top-down one?
Yeah.
That– Something was up there.
Yeah, that's fake. Yeah.
It's a perfect cut-out of him.
Is his shadow a little smaller than him?
It looks a little smaller, yeah.
His shadow's always gonna be bigger.
I'm fairly convinced now,
they didn't actually shoot him spinning on that ground.
They shot him somewhere else and they had to put him into that shot.
So they probably just tracked the ground back in,
rotoscoped him, turn that into a shadow
Basically make him into a shadow on the ground, just slightly offset,
and the effect's done.
But they did a good job with the ambient occlusion. Look at the center of the shadow.
It gets darker.
It works well enough for the moment,
It's over in, like, half a second and then you moved on.
You don't even remember that you saw that shot.
Somebody gonna get a h–
Look at that–
Oh, there we go.
There we go!
(laugh)
Granny style.
So these Bollywood clips are super inspiring, and they inspire me to get better at my VFX game.
And if you guys are the same, then I think today's sponsor is actually perfect for this episode.
It's Skillshare.
And if you guys don't know about Skillshare it's basically an online learning community for creatives who are looking to up their game.
So I've actually been using Skillshare over the last month and–
Patrick Foley has a really great class on creating realistic french fries in cinema 4D and Octane.
He actually goes through the whole thing.
You model the french fries, you actually have ketchup with a nice simulation going, you have salt in the air
and he lights it really, really well.
Really, really cool class.
Skillshare has thousands of classes.
They actually make it really easy to get into,
they're pretty bite-sized, set for any schedule.
They got classes on photography, motion graphics, design, film making, any skill you guys can think of.
So, lucky for you guys, Skillshare is actually hooking you up with two months free of a premium membership to get you guys learning to get your game stepped up.
And honestly, Skillshare is super affordable, less than ten bucks a month for an annual subscription
Now is the time to learn as much as you can, and this is a great way to do so.
All you guys have to do is click the link in the description below for two free months of premium membership and start exploring that creativity.
We love reacting to Bollywood visual effects.
Please, leave a comment down below.
We read all the comments and we'd love to do more of these.
Thank you for subscribing!
We all appreciate it here!
I've imagined watching this and I had a blast.
(accent) "I can't afford to see movies, but I watch the VFX breakdowns on YouTube, and that's pretty exciting."
(laughing)
(laughing) What the heck, dude?
That's your character in a nutshell,
(mocking) "I'd imagine the whole movie's quite nice if you watch it."